I just came back from Vegas and on my
flight back I got stopped in the airport
lounge he's like Evan I saw you speak at
the thing can I ask you questions and
hey grab a seat and we chatted for 20
minutes before she went to her plane
it's similar so she taught guitar so
it's guitar classes not that you know
guitar is Tai Chi but close you know
we're learning we're teaching something
and it's the same component of like
Community plus learning the challenge
that she faces that you'll face that
other people will face along this
journey is there's there's a certain
level of knowledge that people need to
be able to do to be able to practice it
like if you're just starting to teach me
like I don't know where do I put my hand
where to put my legs what am I doing
right like very basic stuff for people
to figure out which once you learn those
basic things you kind of don't want to
do it again you know it's like it's kind
of boring to go back and do it again
except for the I come from the salsa
dancing world and like to say like the
beginners want to learn the intermediate
stuff the intermediate want to learn
advanced stuff and advanced stuff people
go back to the beginning right it's like
to really refine because you think you
got the hand motion but you don't even
know what you're doing with it that's
like super high level but most time like
the intermediates don't want to hang out
with the beginners they'll help but it's
not valuable for them as much to learn
anymore so usually the best way to do it
is to split it where the first part is a
course so the foundation of Tai Chi and
teach me how to do the basic motions so
that I'm ready to go to the group
practice it's either a course or like a
boot camp where you're doing it live
with them but there's a start and an end
and it's a fixed State it's like I will
teach you how to do tai chi inside of
eight weeks
Faith had the winning topic today about
getting a new program launched tell us
quickly what are you trying to launch so
we can Workshop it a little bit more I
teach Tai Chi and Qigong I have for a
long time in person and I'm putting
together an online
School Academy
Community to to teach and you know to
serve right I've spent my whole life
studying this and it's like it's time so
I'm getting that together
it's ready I have a plan but then it's
like I think about social media right
and I'm also a photographer so my social
media you know like I post flowers and
stuff
um and so also to put that topic into
something I can start to share and put
forth to people maybe in my personal but
in my
um community group and and really it's
just like getting started like where do
I start to tell people like hey this is
happening
come join me
who do we want to be in our community is
it is it people who want to learn Tai
Chi people want to teach Tai Chi like
who are the ideal people for this people
who want to learn and practice Tai Chi
got it and and it's a course or it's a
membership it's meeting with you once a
week or month or what what do I get if I
join I'm going to have
a couple of different options I'm going
to have live Zoom classes
that will meet weekly okay
um recordings will be available to those
students after so I want to have like
that place they can go and have their
references I'm also going to do some
recording classes so people can have
that option if they just want to do
recordings and then Community is such a
big thing that I'm going to also have a
community site where the students can
interact with each other and get support
I know you know I I I'm not a Tai Chi
practitioner my sister was Hardcore into
it
um how much of it is practice versus
learning like I mean at the beginning
there's a lot of learning techniques and
the movements and breaking it down how
much of it is
if I'm an intermediate student now how
much of it is like do I get bored in the
beginner class or is it kind of it's
still helpful uh it is Progressive
learning
and so as a student goes through the
program the the courses continue so
practice is a big part of it because Tai
Chi is a practice
and it's one of the things that
I want to address because if you just go
to class it's not a follow-along kind of
a situation right like I really want
people to embody it and take it home and
do it right but the there'll be an intro
class that will be alive but eventually
that intro is going to go more into a
recording with Live Support
sort of like what we're doing here
because as people go once they go
through the intro they're ready for the
next course and they're ready for the
next course
but they can't start up here because it
really doesn't make any sense you know
they have to have the building blocks
that's part of the challenge yeah well
there's I mean so you know with every
challenge is an opportunity and um I
just came back from Vegas met Zayn there
I was speaking an event with garyvee and
a bunch of people and uh on my flight
back I was there early because you never
know like getting to Canada if there's
going to be delays or whatever and and I
got stopped in the um the airport lounge
he's like Evan I saw you speak at the
thing can I ask you a question so hey
grab a seat and we chatted for 20
minutes before she went to her plane and
she taught it's similar so she taught
guitar
so it's guitar classes not that you know
guitar is Tai Chi but close you know
we're learning we're teaching something
and it's the same component of like
Community plus learning the challenge
that she faces that you'll face that
other people will face along this
journey is there's there's a certain
level of knowledge that people need to
be able to do to be able to practice it
like if you're just starting to teach me
like I don't know where to put my hands
why where do I put my legs what am I
doing right like very basic stuff for
people to figure out
uh which once you learn those basic
things you kind of don't want to do it
again you know it's like it's kind of
boring to go back and do it again except
for the I come from the salsa dancing
world and like to say like the beginners
want to learn the intermediate stuff the
intermediates when I learned advanced
stuff and advance that people go back to
the beginning
right like to really refine because you
think you got the hand motion but you
don't even know what you're doing with
it so that's like super high level but
most time like the intermediates don't
want to hang out with the beginners
they'll help but it's not valuable for
them as much to learn anymore so usually
the the best way to do it is to split it
where the first part is a course
so the foundation of Tai Chi and teach
me how to do the basic motions so that
or movements or whatever whatever it's
called
um so that I'm ready to go to
the group practice
so there's there's it's either a course
or like a boot camp where you're doing
it live with them but there's a start
and an end and it's a fixed State it's
like I will teach you how to do tai chi
inside of eight weeks or or whatever 20
weeks 16 weeks four weeks however long
it takes you to do it right
but you have people start together or
it's a course where it's Evergreen and
they're following along so that when
they get to the community side of things
if it's a weekly practice that you're
doing like hey join me every day at 9am
Pacific or whatever and we're gonna go
do tai chi together it's less
instruction of how to do it and more
just community of us doing it together
does that make sense
um and then on top of that you could
sell more private one-on-one of like how
do I how do I really master
that move or how do I use Tai Chi with
my hip that's hurting me or how it's
like all sorts of different custom
things that people then ask like you
know they want to go deeper and so
that's when you sell the one-on-one at a
higher level so there's there's course
or boot camp at the beginning
it's just basically planning for the
fact that the beginners will get to the
intermediates and the intermediates will
start to get bored and so they're not
all mixed into the same group
right so Boot Camp or or workshops or or
course
teach it in eight weeks then it goes to
the community side where and they're
paying like less teaching but just more
community in every it could also be
people who you have who lead this it's
not always you who has to lead it it
could be a daily thing every day like as
you build and scale and grow every day
there's a new there's a new Tai Chi
Community thing to do it together like
in our Park here people go and do tai
chi every morning and it's a community
thing where they run through the same
sequence together even if they haven't
met each other
right like if I like my sister could go
and meet other people I've never met
before and they just they know how to do
the same motions in the park together
um so now I don't have to practice by
myself now I've got this Zoom Community
people to do it
uh and then you're the you're you're the
top are you the queen or you're the head
um and if people want more one-on-one
access then that's what they go to you
for
how does that set
yes that that sits great and actually
lines up with what I was thinking in
terms of bringing people in and the
progression because you can't yeah
you've got to progress them and you
can't mix them and that's that's sort of
always the challenge so
one question related to that right is we
talk about social media and this can
apply for anything that we're putting
forth right and like posting and you
know content and all of that
do you have any suggestion on how to you
know like do you just put little quotes
or like like I don't really know how to
do the social media part and start to to
propagate that to you know kind of bring
people into the
whole thing
yeah so okay let me let me pull up your
account and then we can we can we can
dissect it together here get some
feedback so is this it this is the one
uh no that's my Instagram photography
thing that I don't really do anything
with I have I don't have a handle on
Instagram oh okay cool well so
anyway but you know what this is a good
indication of like what I normally do
cool but that's not that's that's next
right so you know your founder of your
school awesome says Tai cheek you got
cool awesome
um whether you want to update this one
to become the brand or we're gonna
launch a new one for the brand in terms
of making content everything can work I
mean we're seeing the biggest success
right now with reels I talked about that
mover makers a few times but reels are
performing just insanely well super
short clips
um and obviously we need to talk about
Tai Chi we need I mean it's great to
have flowers and stuff but we need to
talk about tai chi on our on our Tai Chi
account that people know that they can
get access to you and what you're up to
and the value of Tai Chi and what is
we're targeting beginners like what is
Tai Chi how can it help you how has that
helped you know you personally how has
it helped the students in your class not
as a sales pitch but but value-add and a
good indication of type of content to
make is look at the people who you're
following
so let's see who you're following so if
I click on who you're following Evan
Carmichael okay good follow I follow
personal development coaches only and a
few photographers on my Instagram nope
but that's good like if you look at
these people
you you take like you follow them for a
reason they make you feel some they make
you feel a certain way you know you love
their message you know you're following
Tom and Jamie and Mel and and other Mel
and Anthony and I mean these are all my
friends this is great
um
so what is a what is it about then that
makes you
want to follow them and whose content
are you like most engaged with and and
your job was to take and capture some of
that feeling but put it inside the world
of Tai Chi
so your message isn't that off from Amal
Robbins or Jamie Kern Lima just the
packaging is through Tai Chi instead of
a speech
does that make sense
yes am I am I am I too out there like
talking
not at all and and really when I when I
look at you know what they're putting
forth right it's yeah it's good I mean
my Instagram it's sort of like when I
scroll it it's sort of like personal
development 101. but
um and that's fine and that's what you
do
that like Tai Chi is Person of element
it is yes it's just not through speeches
it's through motion right right like
people people leave
my side of my sister like to come out
more confident more more self-aware more
um more self-belief more connected like
all all of the benefits that you get
from personal development just you're
teaching it through motion as opposed to
you getting on stage and
and speaking or writing the book
personal development in Tai Chi are not
like
two totally separate entities you're
you're accomplishing the same thing just
through different different ways so
that's the point like if you take of who
you love about personal development and
and then take that part and throw it
into Tai Chi
so we're talking about how to or we're
showing how to have more belief or
self-awareness to self-respect through
the motion of Tai Chi I wouldn't stress
out too much about having the Perfect
Picture Perfect video or anything yet
um just get started because you don't
have you haven't started on that new
account yet or transition your account
um but yeah if you can mix that like
personal development that you love mix
it with Tai Chi and that gives birth to
you know the content that's how you
start to post content that's going to
win
okay that's really helpful thank you
thank you
it's a weird thing to say that personal
development is Tai Chi you know like
that like they're we're both getting
into this but it is it is no it is
you're right I love that so you have to
capture the essence of personal
development and mix it with Tai Chi and
now we've got special Faith brand that
nobody else can can match awesome thank
you for that thank you so much
Celine was asking what's the best way to
get one-on-one clients so honestly the
best way is through referrals as much as
I'm like a Content guy and I love making
videos and content but the best way is
through referrals like do a kick-ass job
with the people who you are doing work
with so that one they want to hire you
back depending on what you're selling
until they introduce you to other people
that like this person is so good that
they want to tell their friends about
you and and being most people won't give
her give a bad service like if somebody
asked you if you ask them how good was
my service they'll probably say oh yeah
yeah you did great but is it so good
that they want to then like you're
forcing them or guilting them to tell
their friends about you and a lot of
times that comes from
helping them Beyond just the thing that
you're helping them with like they're
coming to you for a reason cool but the
concept would be their chief goal
officer like what are they actually
trying to accomplish and go help them
accomplish that right so think about I
just came back from Vegas and I was
speaking an event and most speakers
pretty much every speaker flies in and
flies out and that's her thing right off
to the next thing my favorite thing is
to hang out in the hallway afterwards so
I speak on stage and then speak so much
in the hallway that Zane has to pull me
aside and say sorry guys last question
he has to go to bed
which is usually Nina's job but she
wasn't there so Zayn became my my Nina
uh for the for the for the for the trip
and and by the way zandina was very
grateful that you uh stepped in and and
uh helped with that because I I'll get
sick because I'll spend so much time
helping people in the hallway
um but if you think about it like what's
the goal of
what am I being paid to do like to come
and speak cool but then I'm gonna stick
around in the hallway and help everybody
afterwards because that's helping the
client even so much more
right and then you get hired to come
back and then you get if they're
thinking about who are they going to
recommend to other people to speak
they're gonna they're gonna often pick
me because of the extra work that you're
putting in so it's not that you're not
doing a good enough job it's like well
but they got a result cool but did you
help them so much that they feel like
almost guilted into trying other ways to
help you out
and so referrals is the number one way
to grow a one-on-one client business if
you're a service-based business the the
fastest way to grow it is through
referrals
now that doesn't necessarily scale
right that's not how you build a you
know 10 million dollar company
but it's the fastest way to get going
and get started if we're going to use
content so if you look at build to serve
we tend to always focus on the cloud
leadership and the content but
there's three strategies at the back of
the book on how to win right there's the
fast pass of Freedom there's
Partnerships and then there's thought
leadership and partnership is basically
what we just talked about it's like
referral strategies
uh for the content
that the best way to do it is to do the
thing that you're doing live on inside
your content so Zane wants a
self-confidence coaching he should be
doing confidence coaching as part of his
content calendar we had somebody in
brand Linux this morning uh who was
doing she helps actors
uh get get into Hollywood you know and
all the tips and so one of the video
ideas we came up with was her doing
critiques of people's audition reels so
to get into a film you have to do an
audition reel and send it in they never
get feedback on whether it was good or
bad they just know if they got the pot
or not so have them send the audition
reel to her
and she'll put a make a video on it
breaking it down and critiquing it and
saying all the points where where it's
falling apart like here's why you didn't
got hired I think we were going to call
it like why you didn't get the role or
something and she basically breaks down
and tells you why you didn't get hired
for the job what's wrong with it
if she wants to sell those services
it's much easier to get clients with
that kind of content than with here are
five ways to win in Hollywood
because the fact that you can speak
doesn't mean you're gonna be a great
coach
so what are you trying to sell and then
show me you doing it
right but the easiest way would be
referrals so I don't know what you're
selling
um slim are we're trying to get clients
towards but go in even for free so Drew
and Jeremy are two people who I both
invested into and train the YouTube side
of things and they both have mid six
figure businesses now Jeremy would start
a little sooner Jeremy went from being a
stock boy at a grocery store making
minimum wage to then now having a mid
six figure business and he's like I
don't know if I want to work more than
35 hours a week it's like oh my gosh
describe
uh he's spoiled now Jeremy if you watch
me play you are spoiled
um
but how we started was it was a lot of
free calls because he wasn't very good
at the thing yet and so we did free
calls free YouTube breakdowns basically
pulling up somebody's Channel and do
breakdowns and that led to then some
people on the free calls would have
would call him back and say hey that was
really good how do I can I hire you
and that becomes the goal it's like you
ultimately want to be hired
but are you doing a good enough job on
the free today people to say wow I want
I want to hire this person to come back
so it's Outreach
Zane had a great point today in
brandlytics where we were pulling up
somebody's Channel we didn't know who
they were it's just like using them as
an example he's like could you reach out
to them and tell them to fix their
thumbnails
and offer that as a service like yep
yep like if that was my business or
Drew's business you could reach out and
say hey here's what's here's what's
wrong with your channel here's what I do
I'd love to help you fix it and some
people might just talk to you for half
an hour and take your ideas and run with
it cool and some people will say wow
that's awesome how can I hire you to do
that because I don't want to do that
myself
and then those people hire you you then
you do a kick-ass job helping them and
then they find more ways to work with
you and refer you off to their friends
so that's the easiest way service-based
business to get your company off the
ground is referral based marketing by
doing a kick-ass job for them
the content is the scalable way to build
the business cool so let's uh let's turn
into some questions who's got something
how can I help put your hand up and uh
let's go through lady Lexi what do you
got so when you were talking earlier
about
um the whole response video I was
wondering because you do a lot of those
shorts where your team does on your
gaming channel
and I would really like to respond to
you and get into it so I noticed that on
Tick Tock you can do some stuff like a
duet or stage but what do you do when
it's only on on YouTube so can I post a
part of your video like uh picture in
picture what what what's the norm
you need to use something it's like
these is probably Zoom
where you screen share and then have you
on as well and just adjust the size of
you
like if I were to go screen share right
now you I mean we're doing Movie Makers
right I mean you see my PowerPoint
and then you see me still talking and
you can I can adjust the size of me to
be whatever
I make it small so you can see the
slides it's not like giant Evan covering
everything up but you can make it that
like ladies half the screen and whatever
you're reacting to is on the other half
that's probably the easiest way
and when it comes to title uh would I
say a response to you or would I create
a more catchy title
I would I would lead with a more catchy
title
and then
afterwards if it's not working you can
always look to split test it
okay so for example in in brand Linux
this morning we had a guy who was um
he's a copywriter for books for book
marketing
and he's already ranking at the top for
all of the like book copy marketing
keywords but nobody's searching for it
it's like is it really small people
aren't looking book marketing copy so
he's ranking for all those but it's not
helping him drive his business forward
too much because nobody's searching for
those words
um so one of the things he does is he
does Amazon uh sales page copy so when
you write a book you need to have an
Amazon page and there's copy on the
Amazon page and we went together and
looked at the four hour work week
Amazon page and it sucked
it's got like two paragraphs there's
almost nothing on there so that could be
a good video for him of tearing apart
the four hour work week page and saying
why it sucks and how to fix it
so the video if you look at a title in
that video it should be something about
the 40 work week and how much it sucks
as opposed to my response to the four
hour work week sales page like something
that's going to catch attention so
people want to click on it
now it's ideally not just tearing it
down but then giving feedback right like
here's here's how to make it better
fired what you
watching and of course you got inspired
by descriptions on YouTube
yeah that's amazing
call themselves I don't think I've ever
heard anybody say that before ever I got
inspired by YouTube descriptions okay
this is great you know that you're like
obsessing over YouTube when you lead a
question with I got inspired right
YouTube description so my God you're
basically living inside YouTube right
now lady likes you okay I love it I love
it let's go what do you got oh I'm I'm
living in a Luma Fusion right now
it's a whole different ball game anyway
if then calls him self-confidence coach
and I've been looking for a while how to
call myself today I was thinking about
um calling myself
um what was it called again inclusion
influencer because it does have the the
word inclusion in there and I actually
like to see myself as an influencer
that's way easier than coach therapist
and trainer whatever
okay so you're asking what I think about
inclusion influencer yes it's okay I
don't know that I would I don't know
that I would lean on an influencer I
think it it's uh it still has a
22 year old up and coming vibe to it as
opposed to like if you're actually an
expert at it
so like inclusion experts I also saw
inclusion Creator passing by
yeah expert or Advocate or leader or
like just something with a little more
if it were me something with a little
more
uh gravitas to it if you know gravitas
uh what's uh
a little more stature to it
yeah
influencer I think people will
self-identify as influences and they
might look for I mean if you calling if
you're looking at uh inclusion
influencer it's something that nobody's
looking for like nobody's going to
YouTube or Google anywhere and typing I
need to find an inclusion influencer
right so so now it's a branding play
like what do we want to call ourselves
is this is not for not for somebody
searching so like if somebody's trying
to find a confidence coach then they can
find Zan and they you kind of get a
sense of what it is right like he's a
coach he's gonna teach me confidence
that's what I assume it is if I go talk
to him and he's trying to sell me dog
food or something like this there's
something wrong here so but what's it
what's uh
inclusion influencer like you're you're
it's not immediately understandable so
it's fine it doesn't have to be but if
you're going to then pick something
that's not immediately understandable
then let's pick something that
speaks to speaks to the you know
Prestige I guess that you're going after
so if you're going to call yourself an
inclusion leader or Advocate it just
comes off I think more powerfully than
influencer
Zoom user in the house welcome aboard
Zoom user what do we got everyone my
name is Lily
yeah so um actually coming from a
caregiver uh uh line of work and I'm now
uh going to start uh coaching whereas
how caregivers can reunite families
especially coming here to Canada and how
are they going to start Canada in the
house I love it okay great I'm from
Toronto we're just neighbor oh wow we're
not we're neighbors
so that's what my idea but uh yeah
you're spoken about the VA so I'm
thinking uh where to get the help for a
VA so to set up my back office and so to
to make this like you know like already
set up before I start my webinar
so two options
one would be any personal connections
that you have a lot of the Home Care uh
people at least here in Canada are from
the Philippines yeah that's right so if
you already have connections in there
there's a lot of people in the
Philippines also who are doing VA work
as well
um so it could be personal connections
and saying let everybody know in in the
in your caregiver community that you're
looking to hire somebody in the
Philippines to help with your VA work
and you might you know land on somebody
great
um the good thing about that is they're
connected to the to the caregiver
Community already because they're
their friend their family of somebody
who is a caregiver here in Toronto right
or Canada yeah yeah um so those are some
recommendations
um and that's just letting your friends
know and letting the people letting your
customers know hey I'm looking to hire
somebody who can do this for me the
second is uh we use upwork it's a up
like up and then work is where you can
hire people
around the world for different projects
um if anybody is hiring like you can
just go a lot faster
when you have people helping you and it
doesn't have to cost a lot of money like
when I was given the advice to Maria
I could have said hey Maria you go out
and make this list and you go out and
and she's already rolling her eyes she
could do it but
for the amount that it's gonna cost her
it's it's just not worth it right it's
just not worth it for her to put the
list together and emailing people but
for her to be on the first call
absolutely like we don't want Dylan on
is anybody here named Dylan I don't
think so we're using Dylan as an example
okay
um we don't want Dylan to be making the
first call because he probably won't
know what to say we need that to go to
Maria so like where is the highest
leverage for her part-time worker
overseas
um just makes a lot of sense and for a
lot of people like that's a great job
you know a lot of people who work for me
um
did not did not like their job prior
might have been traveling two or three
hours out of town like each way to get
to their job and come back to do some
call service you know call call center
service work
um you're going to treat them like a
human being like they their boss I mean
most bosses suck so here you are like
actually caring about them
um so it's a great it's a great life for
them as well not just you know you get
work off your off your plate
um so yeah upwork is great what I'd
recommend for anybody who's looking to
hire an upwork is
even for even just hiring period work on
something small together first
work on something small together first
make sure you like them make sure
there's a good vibe there make sure
they're
um they're skilled they're doing the
work well
um they're not you know taking longer
than they should
um they're not
asking dumb questions or asking no
questions right like it's a good vibe
and so when we hire
we might we might end up hiring 10 or 20
people for a position where we have one
opening and
we it's paid so like it's not just
volunteer for us but we'll pay them to
do a trial job and whoever really need
is the Nina's the asset test now you
know like if you're going to work at our
company you have to get along with Nina
oh there's problems so so hey if you if
you like work Nina likes working with
you boom you're hired let's go and you
have the skill set obviously but it's in
that you know we'll give we'll hire
people for up to five hours on a job we
think should take two hours
wow amazing
and then if the person who we like
working with the most who also brings
you know does the job obviously but it
was a pleasure working with then um then
we'll go deeper with them
um and that's what I love doing like
it's for me it's still Vibe first and
then this is like for submit here and
we're still around but
um
when you're hiring it's it's Vibe first
too like heart first he's there he's on
his phone like heart first on the hiring
and then still ahead you're not just
hiring somebody because you love them
when you think it's everything's gonna
work out and be amazing they still have
to be able to do the job but but heart
first like if you went to work and you
love the people you're working with
then um a lot more great things can
happen you know I mean like I see Zane
here when Zane Dan and I were talking
about
um him and Movie Makers and being
involved helping in the early you know
the intros for it and being the built to
serve coach
I was looking for a bill to serve coach
you know like I didn't I didn't I didn't
I didn't want one it wasn't it was not
on my roadmap or idealist but Zane was
one just so amazing as a human pouring
so much love into other people
and how much love he had for Bill to
serve was amazing like he knows the book
better than I do
uh He's like Paige 85. here's what it
says he's got copies that are falling
apart because he's read it so much like
the pages are falling out and all over
the place uh it's just like I love this
human
we should I need to do something with
him
like I need to find a way to do
something more with him and so that it
led to this right so I think you should
yeah Vibe first and so you won't know
that just by um
by a cover letter
it's also like the recommendation to
Chris to actually fly out or drive out
eight hours to go see the guy because he
can feel like the heart
you'll get a you'll get a better
structure and a better deal likely than
even definitely over an email but then
doing it over a zoom
yeah
thank you so much
I have a technical question though if I
if I want to search for people on
Instagram in my Niche because I also
work with women that are wanting to
release weight and more emotional eating
and it's a sensitive issue
um
do I just in the search put hashtag what
I'm looking for and then what happens or
tell me what to do like the technical
piece yeah yeah so in the search bar at
the top it depends if you're using
desktop or mobile but still this you can
search you put in hashtag emotional
eating
but then it brings it'll often bring me
to like somebody who's well like I just
put in women weight loss and then it
comes to some like a coach that's like
that's her page
so at the it'll give you options you can
do people and also say hashtags you can
click on the hashtags and then see okay
another way around it is you when you're
searching like woman weight loss don't
put a space in there
because hashtags can't have spaces right
I mean sometimes underscores whatever
but but you will get a mix of people who
are also doing what you're doing those
are the people that we want to skip
okay right like more than one comes up
like you go to different hashtags so
when you go to that hashtag does it open
up all I'm sorry I'm like really
learning how to do Instagram yeah yeah
yeah yeah no that's good when you click
on a hashtag it'll show you what
the top posts are for that thing and
then the most recent posts as well oh
it'll show me the posts okay and then
and then you can click on them and see
so you're you're going after the people
who are not like you unless you have a
model right like maybe part of Chris's
new business could also be
also helping other people who are
trainers train better
you know like if you're searching up Dad
bod he'll get some people who are also
trying to promote their
personal training business yeah and he
could reach out to them and say hey I've
been doing this for X number of years if
you need help growing your business
I I'm happy to hop on a call and help
you
right so that's a different model I
don't know if Chris wants to go after
that audience or not other other
trainers he's like maybe like cool you
know like ditch it I don't care
options right so they're your
competition and you don't you don't have
anything to help them with then you skip
them and move to the people same thing
for you like you'll have you'll have
emotional eating as a hashtag and you
get some people who are deeply in it and
are frustrated with it and are just
seeking some kind of validation or
emotional support by posting on
Instagram
and that's a very empathetic Outreach
you'll have other people though who are
making fun of it who are posting like a
cartoon or a funny meme or and so then
you lean in on the humor and you can say
hey but if you actually strung with us I
could help you
and your and the goal is to flip them
and so just play with both and then see
which one one feels more natural and
heartfelt for you and two where you're
getting results from people
yeah
I have one more question if that's okay
yep so my work really lends itself to
working in collaboration with
nutritionists with um you know I'm a
food psychology coach but I I work
really with addictive you know the
addictive piece of doctors people that
have clients that are struggling and
they know what to do but they just can't
do it
so is that something on Instagram that I
would do like maybe reach out to people
with those niches also and and see about
some form of collaboration yep Instagram
and maybe LinkedIn
this is where I would see like the
challenges that the people who are at
the top
probably aren't making a lot of content
like the top Professionals in almost any
field are not making a ton of content
most of them
so are the top doctors making a ton of
Instagram content probably not maybe but
in professional Fields doctors lawyers
accountants generally really suck at
making content that just all referral
based business and they're not you know
some are but for the most part they're
not
um but you could like if you put
nutrition tips
or nutritionist you know as as a search
in Instagram you'll see who's posting
although those people are they're giving
their nutrition tips or their
nutritionist uh you have to do a little
bit of work to see how you know is this
person of a certain level I don't know
how you know they're just getting
started maybe it's not worth the time
um but that's a great way to find
partners for your business especially if
it's anywhere in the US like if you can
partner with somebody in LA or in
balmy Cleveland
yes you know
um yeah it's a great way to be able to
find people and set up some partnership
Arrangements you'll just get a bunch of
people who also are at the early stage
of their company and may not be able to
give you a lot of referrals so it might
be there might be some Tire kicking
there
um until you find the ones you can you
can gain a sense like do they have their
own location you know do they have a
retail Center do they have a place you
can actually go visit them or is it just
a home office or all online you know
just to have some criteria for who you
work with but um I love Partnerships
because
they can instead of going one to one to
one to one now you're targeting one
person they can introduce you to ten 100
000 people yeah yeah well my had my
brick and mortar business my best
referral was through a naturopath Clinic
because they had me go there regularly
meet the clients and and they you know
they weren't able to do what the
naturopath was asking them to do and I
was helpful in helping them do that
could you do that anywhere in North
America
yeah if I mean virtually yeah I mean
honestly it might even be better since
you've already done that with naturopath
clinics
um I would look at hiring a VA
to make a list of every naturopath
clinic in North America
and then give them a give them a Maria
lipuma email address
you know Dylan at Maria lipuma
and now Dylan is emailing everybody to
say
hey would you like to talk to Maria
about this
right that's great and you create a
little script for them to send off like
Dylan is not a full-time person at your
company Dylan's just researching and
sending out emails from your company
and then when they say yes most people
will ignore it or goes to spam or
whatever great
and then some people will say okay yeah
let's hop on a call
and then Dylan gives it to you and Maria
takes over honestly like that's if you
have that model already worked out it's
already happened for you that'll be
faster for you to grow your business and
I can use testimonials and all that in
the yeah all you need to do is get
somebody on a call
because you've already done it before
that'll be much faster than doing it
through social media
okay so so hiring a VA to get me a list
of the naturopaths in North America and
sort of create an email that they can
just send out inviting them to have a
chat with me
okay great great idea thank you Evan oh
thank you so much for what you bring I'm
just amazed by you you're an amazing
powerful power of example I know I'm
embarrassing you but really
I'm gonna turn I'm going to turn this
red now I'm going to turn that color on
my face now because of you Maria
um but let's as much as I love content
and YouTube it's not always the best
Next Step
right like honestly for you you just
need to have enough of a profile that if
they look you up on Instagram there's
something there or YouTube like there's
something there if I put in your name
like who is this Maria person is she
legit there's something there that shows
enough of what you do
um yeah and then the VA is making the
email list
you have to make the email don't expect
them to like write the email right you
make the email and then the VA is
sending out the email
how many how many naturopath clinics are
there in North America
I mean
crazy a lot yeah I mean in my town in
the next two towns around here there's a
lot yeah so if you have like if you get
one percent of one percent of one
percent you already have more business
than you know what to do with that's
great yeah well thank you so much that's
wonderful great advice
Tanya what do we got hello Tyson today
my lucky day okay so uh what do you do
when you launch something and it goes
terribly
what do you mean it goes terrible
because
um I I normally do lives for my company
and uh
normally between like fairy and Beauty
people and we don't really do like it's
organic just you know people that and
I've been doing this since once like
probably two or three months ago once um
Sans suggested you should go live every
week and I started doing it and it has
been working well more appointments
really nicely so I started thinking okay
let's do something else something
different so we um I you know uh
proposed uh we should do a workshop a
paid Workshop to have people who's only
interested in actually you know
um doing the the registration in the
programs we have and I uh said well we
should do like a very low fee just to
have the commitment and and kind of like
to test the market which is something
that we have also took uh in these
meetings so I did that and um and I was
uh you know I had a conversation with
one of the colleges here in in Canada
with Seneca College which is fairly big
and they even give us they even gave us
some budget to do the you know the the
promotion and all so we use the budget
and everything so we had people asking
we had people you know lots of likes
lots of cards and all that but it's a
little bit embarrassing but just one
actually payment came through just one
okay this one and it's today okay and
it's coming up or or it hasn't happened
yet
it's today yeah today at 7 p.m oh good I
so so listen this is great like
one is worse than zero right it's better
like if nobody shows up because then you
don't have to do anything right but one
person shows up and then it's like one
person
um
you lean into it
right like you lean first off are you
is there anybody who you're afraid of
disappointing right obviously we're
afraid of disappointing the one person
who paid for the thing because we we
need to give them value are we afraid
that like Seneca is going to be upset
that we didn't get more people or is
there anybody is there anybody besides
the one person that you're afraid of
disappointing
yeah like
it was probably yeah my the the rest of
directors in the in the firm were not
that happy
um in the sense that you know I I kind
of like uh
promoted these and uh instead of doing
what we regularly do and uh you know
they were not that happy but at the end
it's not the end of the world the worst
part would be
um those the person who paid but it's
just one so I don't have a problem I'll
have the consultation with him
um you know a free consultation and that
will pay whatever he paid because it was
just ten dollars it was just very very
little fee just to get those who are
really interested so that's not it's
more like
to like what should I like I don't think
it's gonna be a good idea even if we
have a couple more registrations I don't
think it's a good idea to do the
workshop Maybe
I don't know if it's better just to meet
with them one-on-one or maybe should I
go under the workshop and kind of like
swallow the the the the the the bad
moments like with three people there and
of course I had to explain I have to
explain Seneca College that this didn't
work the market the market I work with
it's very
tough in that sense of pain so and this
was a test yeah so it didn't work it's
kind of like I mean that moment that
what should I do now
you make a list of anybody who you're
afraid of like the judgments and then we
attack the list so if it's your if your
uh directors at your firm are upset you
can you can handle that like you know
how to talk to them it's a test guys we
need to test we can't just keep doing
the same thing and instead of me
spending my time doing personal stuff
I'm spending time on this like this is
this is an attempt right so we can we
can handle them Seneca if you're worried
that you spent their money and it didn't
get a result well what else could we do
to deliver value for them build the
relationship right it's just like
there's lots of things that you could do
that either are outside of this one
this one um advertising
you know mistake air quotes uh that you
can just bring value to that
relationship like if I went and I
totally bombed on uh Brendan wants me to
speak at his event next month right if I
go upstage and like forget what I'm
gonna say and just totally bomb cool I
can make it up to him like if something
happened and I sucked on stage I could
make it up I would find a way to make it
up to bring incredible value to him and
his team so you can make it up to the
people of Seneca
um so the one person you just go and
crush and give them tons of value right
I mean you can even lean into it it's
like hey this was a test for us
you're the you're the person who took
action I love you like let's go and and
you just again you focus on who you have
instead of who you don't if I look at
this like you know how many people do we
have live here why if it was one person
it was you me and Zayn we would still do
this and we'd have a good time helping
we've got I don't know 12 people if it
was a hundred people like we'd still
it doesn't like you can make the
decision whether you keep going or not
but you can you can bring tons of value
to that one person so that helps
alleviate everything because you can you
know you can make it up to everybody you
know you can bring value to everybody
and nobody's going to be pissed at you
after today right cool
the next thing I pay attention to is did
you love the thing like my first
speaking gig in Toronto was that the
YMCA for free and three people showed up
after I promoted it and they promoted it
for free in a giant room I show up with
this giant like Auditorium and there's
three people who are there like oh my
gosh what is this I feel like the
biggest failure of all time
um and I decided Well I already did my
presentation like I already know I
already prepared so much and I was so
nervous because it was one of my first
presentations and um
I just went and did it and it was
amazing
you know it's like I have to I have to
keep going and logically it doesn't make
any sense like if if I promoted it and
nobody showed up and the YMCA promoted
it to their members and nobody like
nobody three people showed up how am I
ever gonna make this this is not a
business this is stupid
but I loved it
and so I kept doing it and I found a way
right so more important than did this
work do workshops work absolutely
so something in the in the in the
mechanics of it didn't work something in
the marketing and promotion of it didn't
work something in the copy didn't work
something on the in the video didn't
work or the advertising was spent
incorrectly like there's many things
that probably didn't work
that doesn't mean that the project is
dead because workshops work
it's more you do it with this one person
and you see do did I love this
and if you love helping them then you
have one now and you try to fix the
marketing for next time and then you
have three or five or seven or ten or
Twenty or like it just keeps building
but the the test isn't did it work or
not because nothing works the first time
like the the chances of something
working the first time I was talking to
the president of Shopify right and you
guys know Shopify like you build your
website and so so
he was saying that all of the um if you
combine all the Shopify stores together
and at Canada's one store they'd be the
second largest store in the world after
Amazon crazy
um and what he said was almost everybody
who's had success on Shopify if you look
at the people who like sold a million
dollars plus through Shopify
it was like their third or fourth store
on Shopify like they had tried Shopify
before and it didn't work out didn't
work out right so like but kept going
started another store where the biggest
mistake is starting one store it doesn't
work oh I guess it's not for me and then
you quit and that's the story of almost
every entrepreneurs like they struggled
and they failed and they sucked at the
beginning and they just kept going so it
definitely can work
for sure workshops work advertising work
it works you just didn't execute it
great
cool
expect to suck and not execute grade at
the beginning is fine you go and deliver
for this person did you love it was it
fun could you imagine 5 10 100 people
there and it being fun yes then you keep
going
um no then you stop you know
so but that's much more of a heart
decision because your your head can
figure it out with enough repetition
went a little I went on a little speech
there but I got excited
it's so exciting because like I can I
can now say you know I felt like the
Biggest Loser of all time when I was at
the YMCA doing that event like I felt
like I wanted to go and hide like I
can't believe I'm such a failure this is
ridiculous plus I pinned my whole career
now like this is what I'm gonna do for
the rest of my life I'm so excited like
oh I can't do this like this is not
gonna work so it's this giant failure
moment
um but I'm so excited that that happened
because now I can share that story right
people will be inspired in in five years
ten years by your success they can say
guys when I started
I got one person it was 10 bucks and
only one person showed up the crate I
felt like the biggest loser
and but I kept going and here's what
happened right
um if you're perfect at the beginning
then it's actually not inspiring other
people
so just going like just give love to
this person go crush it for them
and then see if you liked it and if you
loved it then then keep doing it and if
not you move on to something else
yes I'll have an inspiring speech after
tonight there you go I love it and
listen whenever I'm afraid to do
something
um that'll be one of the things because
I'm I'm afraid of disappointing people
so when I'm afraid of doing something I
will ask myself like can I make it up if
I screw this up can I make it up to
people
you know and the answer is like I can
always find a way to make it up to
people so cool let's do it like when my
tour got canceled
I was my 20
20 tour when did I break my neck 2020
uh 2019 I broke my neck we did it so
2020 I was doing another tour and we had
sold tickets Across America like 22
cities we were promoting spending money
advertising pitching
selling tickets to and I'm I'm about to
go across the border and speak in
wherever like Buffalo or whatever my
first speaking gig and I get denied at
the border and it shuts down the whole
the whole trip
and so now we have to
it's like all these people who bought
tickets to come see me and now I can't
do any of them because I got stopped at
the border and so like panic mode right
away like oh my gosh this is the most
terrible thing of all time I feel bad
for the two people who my camera guy and
my driver who was Jeremy at the time
were coming along and they got stopped
they planned for this
um they're like okay I can make it up to
Jeremy my first like I can make it up to
Jeremy and Ray who are coming with me
I'm going to take him to the to The Keg
which is a kind of fancy Steakhouse here
in Canada and just tell them get
whatever you want just it's on me by the
fanciest steak whatever you want it's on
me because I feel guilty for like you
committed three months of your life to
come with me and now it's all over
and they were fine and I told them I
felt guilty like no no this is great no
worries and then it's all the people who
bought tickets to my event like I can
make it up to them can I make it up to
them yes like a personal message to
everybody obviously refund but like a
refund for me Isn't Enough so it's a
personal message to everybody I think we
even offered like a call
like a call with me if if they have
bought the ticket within a certain
amount of time or something
um so like you can always make it up to
people and people know your heart and
your care and your like the intention
behind this
they're they're pretty forgiving like if
you make a mistake and you own up to it
and you try to make it better it often
leads to just amazing relationships as
well honestly one of my biggest regrets
in thinking about this like get save the
name email phone number contact
information of this one person
so that in five years or ten years we
can like do an IG live with them or
something he's like you were the one
person only one verse like I don't know
who the three people were who that would
be the best thing of all time like who
are the three people who came to my
first thing being able to have them on
now
and say you were there at the YMCA right
I wish I had kind of kept in touch
um so yeah if you had their contact info
that could be a cool now we're turning
into something much bigger but um yeah I
even have his credit card information
well there you go
build a relationship honestly like
follow them on social if they have it
like build like if you love doing it and
it becomes something man that first
person to be able to say only one person
showed up and we're still in touch and
here's what they're doing and and show
the success that you're able to help
them with
yeah I wish I I wish I was smart enough
to think about that when I was first
getting started with those three people
I want to know I don't remember them I
was still nervous and so scared and so
feeling like a loser I can't even see
their faces the three people who showed
up so
um yeah that'd be pretty cool thank you
yeah yeah I think and what you helped me
help me bring value to each of the parts
involved because I'm not afraid of you
know falling down and hit the floor
right you know it had happened before
and I know that I can you know stand up
again I know that so yeah it was kind of
like very disappointing to to to listen
that there was just one registration
yeah but I can't I can survive that but
yes I was concerned about all the all
the other parties really you know that
are involved in this but I think that I
can made up for them and yeah I'll
definitely I'll definitely find a way to
and you gave me with the process of
thinking that so thank you thank you so
much there we go well that's why
Community is so important
if you want to get a copy of build to
serve and join us live for our next
training with me to ask your questions
you can go get the book right there next
to me right there I'll see you there
I'll see you to get the book it's a good
one much love